>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Elizabeth Peterson:
Hello everyone.
My name is Betsy Peterson.
I'm the acting Director of
the Veterans History Project
and on behalf of the staff, I'm
going to welcome you all here today
and I know we have a full and jam
packed program so I'm going to try
and be as brief as I possible can.
The Veterans History Project was
founded by the United Sates Congress
in 2000 and its mission is very
simple and I think very powerful,
which is to collect, preserve and
make accessible personal account
of America's war veteran
so the future generations can
understand the realities of war.
And today since 2000 we have over
100,000 of those personal accounts
in our archives and that serves
up them are on the VHP website
so I want to invite all of
you to come and listen to some
of the interviews here or go on
site and listen to them there.
But we also present programs
which brings us today
and I think today's panel
is a perfect illustration
or demonstration of our
interest and desire to want
to fully explore the
realities of war.
Today is Posttraumatic Stress
Disorder Awareness Day and in honor
of that the VHP staff
wanted to present a panel
that explores those issues
and its impact on veterans.
And so we have assembled with US
Army Staff Sergeant Karen Fears,
a wonderful panel, a veteran
survivor and military personnel,
medical doctors, individuals
who are intimately involved
with these issues here
today to discuss it.
And so without further
ado, I'm going to turn this
over to US Army Staff Sergeant Karen
Fears who will be the moderator
and facilitator for today and
she can provide the introductions
for our panelist but welcome
to all of the panelists
and welcome to our guest.
[ Applause ]
>> Karen L. Fears: Well
good afternoon everyone.
Thank you so much for
welcoming us here today.
Thank you Betsy for the warm
welcome and the background
on the American Folklife Center
and the Veterans History Project
and thanks also to the staff
Andrew Huber, Lisa Taylor,
and everyone here whose
put in this event together.
This is really important work
that we are all involved in.
We all know that raising awareness
of PTSD is the greatest thing
that we can do to help
our fellow veterans
and those seeking assistance.
I also would like to thank our
four panelists for joining us
and bringing us their
personal experiences
and expertise to this event.
I also served as a panelist
exactly two years ago today here
at the Library of Congress
and I'm truly thankful
to God for being here.
As a veteran myself, who
suffers from PTSD as a result
of sexual assault in the military,
this event is truly a platform
to bring awareness of
the severity of PTSD.
And in my healing process what I
learned as one of the main concepts
of overcoming PTSD is to confront it
first versus suffering in silence.
At the VA Hospital in
Seattle, I was a tester
in this program called
"Taking Charge".
And in this program, it allowed--
it had us to relive the scenarios
of our assault while serving.
It was a very difficult
and emotional program
but it was certainly one that I'm
very happy that I participated in.
It helped to establish my
voice, how to set boundaries.
It taught me self defense and
a platter of many deliverables
that I would not have been able to
establish if I had not participated
in a program such as this.
In the research, I also discover
that over a hundred women
participated in this program.
And unfortunately, this
program dissolved in 2015
because of lack of funding.
This is really a disservice to
service members both men and women
because I truly feel
that the program
like this will be very instrumental,
not only for my recovery
but the recovery of others.
Although this issue
has been identified,
there is still a tremendous
amount of work to be done
and more importantly, veterans
and their families should not
have to suffer in silence.
This is an-- this is
not an invisible issue.
It is the issue that all of us
should feel comfortable in speaking
about openly, via family,
professionals and fellow beings
and not be judged by the illness.
So with that being said I would like
to share a few house keeping items.
This event is being recorded
and web-casted via the
Veterans History Project webpage
and if you enjoy the discussion,
your friends and family can view it
at www.loc.gov as it is the
Library of Congress website.
The panelists serving today are
professional experts in their field
and can provide a wealth
of information afterwards
via business card, brochures
or actually just interacting
with them.
Each panelist would be presented two
minutes to provide their overview
of themselves, their services and
lead into discussion thereafter.
In keeping track of time, I will use
my tap on the imaginary watch wrist
on wrist as a timer [laughter].
OK. We would also like to conduct
a Q&A session and we will try
to answer as many questions as
possible and if we happen to run
out of time, please
leave your questions
with the LOC staff for follow up.
We would like to render the
opportunity for everyone to speak.
At the end of this event, there
is a resource table in the back
that has the Veterans History
Project information and the--
and "How to Conduct Military Service
Interviews with the Veterans and How
to participate in their Mission".
So in my opinion, this is a
great day for us to come together
and speak about this issue.
And at this time, I would
like to welcome the 2016 National
Posttraumatic Stress Disorder
Awareness panelist and we will
start with Dr. Glenda Wrenn Gordon,
Dr. Tara Galovski, Dr. Elspeth
Ritchie and Maurice DeCaul.
So we'll start with Glenda.
>> Glenda Wrenn: Well
good afternoon everyone.
I'm really delighted to be
here today and very glad
to have the opportunity to join
this discussion, share my insights
with you and hear the
questions that you may have.
I come from Atlanta here today
where I work at the Morehouse School
of Medicine a faculty member in
the Department of Psychiatry.
In that capacity, I direct the
Division of Behavioral Health
at the Satcher Health
Leadership Institute
under the founding
director leadership
of the 16th Surgeon
General Dr. David Satcher.
I also serve as the
Co-Director of the Kennedy Center
for Mental Health Policy and
Research that was recently endowed
with support from The Kennedy
Forum and Patrick Kennedy.
So I have some aspects of
health policy perspectives
that I hope we can bring
to the discussion today.
I'm also a veteran, a woman
veteran, and have the pleasure
of starting the Women's Center
of Excellence at Fort McPherson
at the Atlanta VA which
is a interdisciplinary,
interprofessional clinic that is
amazing and designed to address
that gap in the VA's ability
to serve women veterans
and their unique needs, so I have
a lot of insights for my work
with patients like yourself
who I have the great honor
of helping walk them through
their journey of recovery
and just look forward
to the discussion today.
>> Karen L. Fears: Wonderful.
Thank you.
Welcome. OK.
Ms. Galovski.
>> Tara Galovski: Hello,
I'm Tara Galovski
and I'm also delighted to be here.
It really is an honor and a
privilege to be sitting at the table
with such esteemed colleagues.
I am the Director of the
Women's Health Sciences Division
for the National Center for PTSD.
That's located in Boston, so I
flew in this morning as well.
We can share a cab going back.
And I'm also an Associate
Professor at Boston University.
I joined the VA fairly recently
actually, within the last 10 months
but I've been a contractor
with the VA for many years
and my former position as
a professor in Saint Luis
where I also directed the
Center for Trauma Recovery.
And my research program
there is developing
and testing interventions
specifically designed
to treat posttraumatic stress
disorder namely cognitive processing
therapy and I've brought those
interests with me now to the VA
where it's truly is an honor and
pleasure to serve our veterans.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
Thank you ma'am, thank you so much.
Thank you for joining us.
And Dr. Ritchie.
>> Elspeth Cameron
Ritchie: Good morning.
It's a real pleasure to be here.
I am local.
I grew up in DC and I came to the
Library of Congress many times
as a child and it's wonderful
to be back here again.
I joined the army because they paid
for medical school
at George Washington.
Growing up in DC your local
medical school, Georgetown, GW,
Howard are pretty expensive.
Best decision I made in my
life, I trained at Walter Reed.
I was just going to
do my time and get out
but the army kept me sending me
more and more interesting places,
Somalia, Guantanamo Bay, Korea,
Iraq and I happen to like travel.
And then I retired
in 2010 as a colonel,
so yes you can call me Colonel
Ritchie I like the title.
[ Laughter ]
And about seven months ago I
joined our local Washington DC.
VA. I sort of joked I
went to the dark side.
The VA has gotten so many hits on it
I figured I had to do something to,
you know, improve the system.
And I actually really like it,
really good people and
people trying hard.
So, I probably have
the shortest ride here.
I don't know about you but I'm
a taxi ride of a few minutes.
My other claim to fame is my great
grandmother taught James Billington
the history and of the
Library of Congress Russian
and so that's how he got
to where he is today.
[ Laughter ]
>> Karen L. Fears: OK, wow.
Thank you.
Welcome. And Mr. DeCaul.
>> Maurice DeCaul: Hi everyone.
It's a pleasure to be here
with you today and pleasure
to be with my other panelist.
So thank you for having me.
So I joined the Marine
Corps in 1997.
I was a artilleryman and
then infantryman based
out of Camp Lejeune, North
Carolina so not too far from here.
I'm actually-- let me move this.
I'm actually from New York so I
took the bus down this morning,
bought a ticket a week
too late for the train.
But what I do, I'm a writer, so
I'm a poet and I'm playwright.
And I came to writing completely
by accident a few years
ago back in 2009.
And I was at Columbia, it's
where I did my undergrad
and the intent was to study history.
I want to be a lawyer.
And when we were waiting for the
new GI Bill to come into place,
I took the year off and found a
writing workshop at NYU and it kind
of changed the direction of my life.
Now, those workshops are
not necessarily designed
to be a therapy they're not
supposed to be therapeutic.
It supposed to be professional
level workshops but I do know
that people receive
therapeutic value from them.
So currently, I am the
Artist-in-Residence
at Theatre Communications Group.
We are the largest theatre service
organization in the United States
and we represent about
770 theatres or so.
And we're prototyping a
program called the Veterans
and Theatre Institute.
What we were hoping to
do is to expand theatre,
to make it more accessible
to veterans, to build demand
for theatre and military
and veteran's communities.
Writing workshops, acting workshops
and we're actually figuring out now
but a little bit of
workforce development as well.
>> Karen L. Fears: Great.
Thank you.
Thank you all for being
here and joining us today.
All right, so Dr. Galovski
we're going to start with you.
>> Tara Galovski: Sure.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
What has been your experience at
working with women veterans rebuild
in terms of challenges and
successes that remain today?
>> Tara Galovski: That's
a great question.
I'll start with successes.
I'll start at that top.
I have seen, men and women,
but women veteran's
lives remarkably change.
I look at posttraumatic stress
disorder very much as something
that does not need to
be on someone's plate.
And we can't change what
happened to any given individual,
that is for sure, but we certainly
can take off that PTSD piece of it
and I've seen that happened.
I'm a psychologist as well.
I always keep a patient load.
I really enjoy working
with patients and it truly,
truly can remarkably
change people's lives.
The challenges are substantial.
Coming into therapy
is very expensive.
Therapy is expensive in terms
of cost but it's also expensive
in terms of your emotions and
the time and the logistics.
It's a process and so
I very much respect all
of our patient's decisions
whether or not they want to engage
in that process but
the challenges are
to increase the access to good care.
>> Karen L. Fears: Great.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
OK. And Dr. Wrenn, in
your professional opinion,
what would you suggest is the most
compounding women health issue
and particularly present
now that combat jobs are
in the military that
are open to us now?
>> Glenda Wrenn: That's a really
big question but I think I'll answer
that by referring to
some recent events.
I don't know if any of you
followed the news and learned
about the womens who graduated from
ranger school in this past year.
One of those women is Lisa Jaster
who's a 2000 West Point graduate
so that was one year behind
me and she's actually a mother
when she graduated
from ranger school.
So I think for all of the years
in which those debates raged
on about whether or not
women were capable of serving
in the combat arms I think that
the tide has certainly changed
which is wonderful but also
brings a new wave of challenges
and taking care of veterans in the
VA it's clear that the Department
of Defense and military still has
active work that needs to happen
to create a culture where all people
are respected, where there is kind
of an intolerance to some of the
environmental factors that lead
to military sexual trauma
being unacceptable outcome
of serving together.
So I think that's really important
just on the front end to make sure
that the military is an environment
that doesn't unnecessarily add
additional trauma exposures.
But the other thing that I
think is important, which is,
both a women's health issue but
also a broader issue is military
cultural competence.
People often talk about that gap
between people that have served
in the military and those that just
have no understanding and I think
as a healthcare provider, we have
a responsibility if we're going
to take care of veterans which is
probably most healthcare providers
whether you know it or not.
There's a responsibility
to know something
about their culture identity, both
racial and ethnic but also how much
to what extent do they connect
with their military identity.
And I think, you know, coming
from Morehouse School of Medicine,
we talk a lot about
culture competence
and I view military culture
competence as a unrecognized aspect
that we really need to do more of.
And that will help women as they
try to navigate their own identities
as they're out of the military,
in the military because it has
to be understood in the context
of to what extent they connect
with that military identity.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
Wonderful, great.
Thank you.
OK. Dr. Ritchie, clearly,
we as women are capable
of being very resilient
while serving in combat.
Now that we are serving in
combat roles, what do you pose
as to why there is
diverted attention
to better off military
women in that environment
and why is that not a priority?
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie: So,
first of all, I want to clear
up one misconception that
many people have, not--
maybe not this audience and that is
that women have only recently
been allowed to serve in combat.
Women have been in
combat for a long time.
I myself are allowed to wear
three different combat patches
from Somalia and Iraq.
What is true is that we haven't been
allowed to serve in certain roles
such as infantry and artillery
and so that's going to
be a bit of a change.
One of the ways I got interested
in this whole topic of women
in the military is I went from sort
of a cush residency of Walter Reed,
where I lived, you know, in DC
and had bathrooms and, you know,
here bathrooms becomes a recurrent
theme when you're in the field.
And then I went and was
the division psychiatrist
for the second infantry division
on the DMC in Korea, hooah.
And shortly after I got there,
Saddam Hussein invaded
Kuwait four days later.
So we went to being
kind of, you know,
comfortable in DC to
being on the DMC.
So all the worries about North Korea
coming down and then the question
about we're fighting another war.
In that time, I was out in
the field a lot, team spirit,
cold when the winds come down from
the plains, from the Russian steps,
muddy, you're out in little
pop tent, kind of miserable.
And that's where the
bathroom thing comes in.
Because you're all to dress to
the ninth with your Kevlar vest
and your helmet and your gas mask
and your TA 50 and, excuse me,
I know you're not going to squirm
here but some of the other guys
in here may squirm
I warn you in this.
You know, when we go
to the bathroom,
we have to take all of that off.
>> Karen L. Fears: We do.
[ Laughter ]
>> Elspeth Cameron
Ritchie: Plus CM 16.
>> Karen L. Fears: Yes.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie: And
we have to find a place to put it.
And you can't just leave
your M-16 on the hanging
out on the porta-patty, you
know, the people might want
to teach you a lesson or
sell it or whatever else.
So what I learned back then is that
women really didn't want to complain
about any of them because we
want to show that we can hang.
We're tough, we're strong.
We're not going to whine--
>> Karen L. Fears: Yes, it's true.
>> Elspeth Cameron
Ritchie: -- not me.
And yet it was an additional burden
and shortening the whole discussion,
through the years, I've learned
that we are at higher risk
for urinary track infections,
for pelvic stress fractures,
how do you manage your menses when
you're in a deployed situation,
all that, all of the
embarrassing stuff
that people don't want
to talk about.
Now the military to its credit
did focus on this area back
in the late 1990s and there was
a lot of research being done.
And then what happened, 9/11
happened and everybody went to war,
first in Afghanistan and then
in Iraq and got real busy
and women's issue kind of
went to the back burner.
Besides if they need
a decent bathroom,
do we really need them
in the military anyway?
And again, there was the cycle
of women didn't want to complain
and we-- because we were worried
we wanted to prove them ourselves.
But what the military has
also learned and this is
at the highest level so I believe
is we need women in our ranks.
We need them to do it right and
so interest has come up again.
Having said that one of my
co-authors of a book I did "Women
at War" in Afghanistan in
2001 looked at the same issues
that I complained about
in Korea and found
that they were still active 10 years
after we've invaded Afghanistan
people not having clean places.
So it is still an issue now.
The nice thing about the formal
recognition of women being
in combat is that there's a
little more attention paid
to women's needs.
And by the way this isn't
just about women as well.
I find that most men over about 40
like to have a decent bathroom too.
And joking aside, what the
military has been very good
at times is integration, they've
been a leader in integration,
they've been slower
on women's rights
and they've been slower
on gay rights.
But now we've taken great
steps forward in the repeal
of don't ask don't
tell moving forward
in just the last couple years,
and I think the next step
is transgender issues.
And recognition that everybody
is important and people who want
to join the military are
raising their hand and saying,
"I would do whatever it takes
to take care of my country."
And that is a breed of person
we really want to support.
>> Karen L. Fears: Great, great.
Thank you Dr. Galovsk.
OK. And Mr. DeCau,
OK, in March 2016,
the Theater Communications
Group launched the Veterans
and Theatre Institute which is
a pilot program for veterans
and active military personnel to
experience study and create theater.
In your experience, how has a
pilot program such as this assisted
in a veteran in their
healing process in PTSD?
>> Maurice DeCaul: So VTI is
brand new and we're not going
to a running size until
September 7th of this year
in Providence, Rhode Island.
But these sorts of
workshops already exist.
So I come from New York and in New
York we have about five of them,
so NYU has one, Fordham has one,
Colombia has one, and there are few
that are not affiliated
with the institutions.
What I've seen as a
participant and also as teacher
in these workshops is, you know,
folks come in and what ends
up happening is a community spill
because oftentimes the people
in the room, they don't know each
other they didn't serve together,
different branches,
different wars even.
And by that, I mean, one of
my workshops we had a Marine
who served in the Korean War.
So it's multi generation.
So the community gets spilled in the
room, first, and I also have noticed
that there was a moment
of catharsis.
You know, the one at NYU the way
that we ran that one, we ran it just
like you would run any
other MFA style program.
So, the writers were
expected to write beforehand,
didn't really have much time to
write in class, and bring the work
in and we would discuss it in class.
And we would offer feedback
and they would go back
and work on their pieces.
But in the beginning of that
workshop, and again even
at Colombia, what you notice, what
I notice is that there was this--
I would say a few months maybe
a year because of programs one
of the academic year where people
are going through the moment
of catharsis where the stories that
are coming out are the war stories
and these, you know,
these sorts of things
that one never really talks about.
On my way down this morning, I was
a reading I finished the book of one
of my friends his name is
Eric Fair [assumed spelling].
Eric was an interrogator in Iraq.
And there are things in
that book that I, you know,
never knew about Eric because
he never shared them with us.
But towards the end of the book he
talks about our program and he talks
about the program being the place
where he was able to start thinking
through some of his Iraq trauma
experience, if want to term it that.
So the workshops give the space
for, you know, for us address some--
you know, the issues that I think
bring-- that follow people home.
But after those two phases the
next phase is it becomes very
professional and people begin to act
and produce work like
any other writer.
By that I mean, you know, we've had
novels come out of those workshops.
We've had books in poetry.
We've turned up many journalists.
So, you know, there are these
phases that I'm noticing.
Again, I'll just repeat it.
The first the community building
and then second is a
moment of catharsis.
And then after that becomes
very professional people
who write like writers.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
>> Maurice DeCaul: And I'm
hoping that we have the same sort
of outcomes with theater,
the programs
and describing a pros
based and poetry based.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
Wonderful.
Great. Thank you panel so much for
the first round of our questions.
The second round we're going
to go into group discussion.
OK. And just feel free
whomever would like to take
on the question just
feel free to do this.
OK. A recent study pointed out
higher rates of PTSD among veterans
who are women along with other
studies that show the same for Back,
Hispanic and Native American.
Why are these findings important?
And is research being conducted
to determine how to combat this.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie: I think
at least three of us are going
to leap in to answer that one.
Why don't I start and I'll be brief.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie:
So in the civilian world PTSD
is higher among women than men.
In the military there's only
limited studies that have been done
which show that it's
about the same rate.
This is when people
are in active duty.
It changes when you become a
veteran different populations go
to the VA the rates changes.
And so the other part of PTSD that's
very different is traditionally
in women who have suffered
sexual assault.
That's a tremendous insult.
It will cause often very bad PTSD.
Woman feels vulnerable, ashamed.
Well if, you know, in combat you
usually have your buddies with you,
you've got your weapons, you
know what you're getting into,
so you certainly have PTSD but it's
not a shaming in the experience.
Again I'll stop there,
there's more I could say
but I know these guys
want to jump in.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK, Dr. Wrenn?
>> Glenda Wrenn: I just want to
add to a point that you brought
up earlier which is the
challenge that people have
in actually identifying what there
symptoms are and what they mean
and then what their decisions
making process is in getting help.
And so I think the data that you're
showing these disparities really
reflect the community and the
cultural differences in terms
of does your social environment
promote identification
of the disorder and promote
and support help seeking
or when you disclose that you were
sexually assaulted does everyone act
like, you know, look around like
why is that a big deal again?
So I think that really is
important and there are
so much more that communities
can do.
Because we put a lot on
the shoulders of those
that have PTSD to get help.
But it's really hard.
It's hard to figure out that
this is what is going on with me.
People just think something
bad happened.
My symptoms are equal to my trauma.
I don't, you know, what
more is there to say.
So by understanding
the signs and symptoms
and recognizing hidden trauma
narratives that you see in others
that you care about you can
play a really instrumental role
in helping them to get to care.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
Great. Thank you.
>> Tara Galovski: And just to
highlight the unit cohesion piece
of both of those the culture
that a trauma occurs
in is really important.
And if military sexual trauma
is onboard then there's a
larger context.
So a recent patient of mine
was describing a situation
where she is over in Afghanistan.
She is the only woman in the unit,
they all experience horrific
combat related trauma.
But she also had this
isolative piece around her
that she couldn't share
with her unit
because there is the
sexual harassment component
that feels very different when
you can't go home from that.
It's bad enough in the
workplace here in the states
but if you can't go home
from that plus the horrors
of war surrounding it there's
an added traumatic stress burden
for women that can be very unique.
>> Karen L. Fears: Great, great.
Thank you.
OK. So my next question is how
is cognitive processing therapy
currently used in the
treatment if PTSD,
and in your opinion is it
the most effective treatment?
Dr. Ritchie?
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie:
Well I am a heretic here.
I don't like cognitive
processing therapy.
So we may have a bit
of a discussion here.
The cognitive processing therapy
and prolonged exposure are
what are called evidence-based.
They've been studied in research
trials and if somebody starts them
and finishes them,
most people do better.
The problem is a whole lot
of people don't want to go
through the 10, 12,
20 sessions needed.
They don't want to be telling the
trauma over and over especially
to somebody who hasn't
been there, doesn't get it.
Now there are strategies to overcome
that and one of the big ones
and I don't think I even
mentioned yes I'm a psychiatrist.
One of the big ones is
engagement with your patient
and making sure they're
ready to get there.
You're going to I think we're going
to talk later about complimentary
and alternative therapies
and I use a lot of those
and I'm a psychiatrist
so I use medication too.
But having said that I think CBT PE,
cognitive processing
therapy prolonged exposure,
do work for some people.
You just have to tailor
the treatment for them.
You can't just say, you know, go do
20 sessions of talking about this
because a lot of people
would just walk away.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
And what are your thoughts?
>> Tara Galovski: I agree
with that to some extent--
[ Laughter ]
-- as one of the developers of
cognitive processing therapy.
So my area of research is to
how much can we take this manual
and bend it until it breaks.
So I absolutely agree that if you
approach these therapies as it
in this cookbook kind of way then
in this absolutely less effective.
And I also absolutely agree
that is not a silver bullet.
This is not-- you know,
that there is many people
that this doesn't happen.
I really appreciate
the many pass to Rome
and I very much appreciate a patient
saying to me this isn't my cup
of tea or I'm not ready yet.
That being said I'll do back flip in
the office to try not to in any way,
shape or form collude
with that avoidance.
And so I think that that might be
consistent with the engagement piece
that you're talking
about because I do--
it's been my clinical and
academic experience that avoiding
that trauma memory which sounds
really good on paper, right?
Why think about the worst thing
that ever happened to you?
But it also keeps people
locked in PTSD.
So cognitive processing therapy,
prolonged exposure, acupuncture
or EMT, there's evidence for
all of these things to work.
And that's a great place to be.
We have lots and lots of choices.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
>> Glenda Wrenn: Yeah.
I mean having trained
under NFO [phonetic],
the PE as a psychiatry
resident I actually one
of my first research projects
was around dropout for PTSD
because I was kind of compelled
by that same finding particular
in African American women.
And working in primary care settings
which is the clinic that we're
at is primarily primary care.
There is a pretty extensive
engagement processes necessary
for some people.
And for me being trained
in a different psychological
modalities it helps
because I can kind of give you
a preview of what to expect.
I can give you the rationale
for treatment and way it works.
I can talk about the neurobiology
of PTSD and why avoidance is bad
and why talking about the
trauma leads to habituation.
Not every psychiatrist can talk
through all of that and I think
that kind of makes it
hard to like go over there
to the trauma recovery program and
they'll do something to help you.
So I think, you know,
that's the piece
that Colonel Ritchie was
talking about, about engagement.
And I don't know that we
know enough about what works
for everyone here and there.
I kind of trust individuals to
figure out what they're ready for
and our job is to kind
to give them information,
maybe you haven't considered this,
I think medications
are really important
but I tell patients I don't even
know that I've ever treated someone
that go all the way better
only with medications.
They did something else too.
You have to reclaim your
natural inheritance originally
and so you have to
engage back in your life
and medication isn't
going to do that.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie: So
I think one area we all agree
on then is that we've got to layout
the different options and we've got
to make sure that it
fits for that person
and at the pace they're ready for.
>> Glenda Wrenn: That's right.
Yeah. OK.
>> Karen L. Fears: And
saying that in my experience
that was the one thing that I
wanted to avoid was having to depend
on a medication for the rest of
my life to function, so thank you.
>> Maurice DeCaul: Can
I just want to-- OK.
>> Karen L. Fears: Absolutely.
>> Maurice DeCaul: So I've
never actually done that,
that sort of therapy.
I've actually not done
any of those things.
And I remember speaking
with a friend
of mine a poet Vietnam air
poet, very well known poet
so I'm not going to use his name.
But he was taking about when he goes
to the VA he undergoes
the sort of therapy.
And he only does it
because he wants his meds.
And he told me once that he sad to
the person that he works with that,
you know, "I've been writing
these poems for 25 years."
So, you know, he's been and he's
been retelling the stories over
and over and over and over and over.
And even in our rooms the writing
rooms is kind of what happens.
The first year people are
telling those stories.
So I think we are doing that
kind of work even in our rooms
without necessarily maybe knowing it
and not being super
intentional about it.
But what I've noticed as
people will go the war stories.
When we start the rooms up we tell
them, you know, you don't have
to write about the war,
you can write about whatever
you want to write about.
But it always is about the war.
I mean, I've run these
workshops all over the country
and it's always about the war.
So it goes-- I think we're doing
similar things, similar work.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
OK. And now this is an
open-ended question.
What can we suggest to congress
to render more attention
to issues involving PTSD
in the military both
from combat related trauma
and trauma experienced
through sexual assault
and other abuse?
Dr. Ritchie may I start with you?
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie:
You may but again I'm going
to be a little bit
of a heretic on this
because I think actually congress
has paid quite of a bit of attention
to posttraumatic stress disorder,
traumatic brain injury and suicide.
Now, whether that's quite enough and
whether it'll sustain I don't know.
An area that they don't think
they've paid enough attention
which we've been looking at is
issues around sexual health and PTSD
and TBI either in people who've
gotten blown up and lost their legs
or their-- excuse my language,
that they're junk and are wanting
to have a family or many of the
medications that are used for PTSD
and TBI impairs sexual health.
So I think there's a lot to lip
service paid to PTSD but we need
to take it a step beyond what
conventionally when you think about,
about two-thirds of the suicides in
active duty individuals are failure
of romantic relationships.
What we don't know is how much
of that is related to impotence,
problems with not getting an
erection, maintaining an erection
and how those problems
can poison a relationship
if they're not talked about.
So I've got a book coming out
this fall "Intimacy Post-Injury",
how can you help people talk about
these even darker secrets of PTSD
and then by talking about
it know how you can treat it
and maintain the intimacy that's
so important to all of us.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
Dr. Galovski do you have
any thoughts on that?
>> Tara Galovski: One thing that's
occurred to me and I don't know
that this would necessarily
take a congressional act
but being a new comer to the VA
and sitting through many hours
of orientation and trainings
and those types of things,
most of actually which
were very interesting,
everyone thought it
was going to be bad
but it was actually
very interesting.
There is a [inaudible] in a culture
in the VA that the soldier is a man.
Every example is that there's-- and
I found myself cut and then women.
And how about the women, you know?
And so I think that given that women
are the fastest growing segment
of the veteran and certainly on
active duty as well population.
I think that a concerted effort
to recognize that soldiers are men
and women and would make it much
more of a safe place for women
to come and take these
kinds of issues,
sexual health absolutely
is one of them.
OBGYN needs to be expanded
but certainly also PTSD
and really the full range of
the women's health spectrum.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
Dr. Wrenn?
>> Glenda Wrenn: For me one thing
that I think hasn't gotten
enough attention in terms
of requirements is that issue
of military cultural competence
training particularly among
healthcare providers that
serve veteran populations
of which now is pretty much everyone
but the choice program and also
for the fact that most veterans
get their care outside of the VA.
Working part-time at the VA myself
I have always been kind of confuse
as to why I have hundreds
of required trainings
on blood borne pathogens
and all kinds of things
but it was never part of the
requirement of on boarding
to have just basic knowledge.
And as a psychiatrist I have talked
with colleagues who worked at the VA
who don't think it's important.
They don't think that's necessary.
And I think that that's
kind of like a darker side
to the healthcare field but now
there are VA sources, Psych Armor
and the Center for Deployment
Psychology have provided amazing
free trainings that can be utilized.
And, I mean, the voluntary
thing is nice but I also think
that it's a requirement I think
to be able to have the skills
that you need to serve
the population
from a healthcare perspective.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie: And
they are moving towards putting
that into medical schools,
the curricular
and other nursing schools.
So there's a lot of grassroots
effort to do that but that's got
to be systematic across the country.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
Great. Thank you.
OK. All right.
The next question is how can
civilian citizens who want
to help veterans best
engage in solutions
to migrate the impact of PTSD?
Dr. Glanda Wrenn, you want
to talk a little bit on that?
>> Glenda Wrenn: Yeah.
I mean I think civilian
citizens can also go online
and take those classes and, you
know, to also reach out to those
in your community whether
it's a faith community
or another community
based organization
that wherever you're engaged in
a civic way I think that's part
of citizenship is kind of building
community and supporting each other.
And the hard thing is that
it's not just competence
but it's also cultural
humility that's required
because you don't know what it means
that a person says
they're a veteran.
You know, that is useful as a
starting point but it's just
as useful as looking at me
and saying I'm an African
American woman.
You have no idea what that
really means who I really am.
So being able to have the
courage to if you find out
or the person discloses that
they are a veteran to have kind
of that cultural humility framework
to say, you know, to what extent has
that really shaped your identity.
Or, you know, I hear
about these other things,
is this something that
you struggle with.
And I think that's something
that civilian citizens may
feel kind of unequipped to do.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
>> Glenda Wrenn: But you can
get the training that you need
and it's really needed because
it's isolative to feel that you're
in a world that you're
no longer a part of.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
Maurice, what are your
thoughts on that?
>> Maurice DeCaul: Well I think
conversation is really important.
You know, at the end of the
day, the people who serve
in military are your brothers,
sisters, sons, daughters.
So, I think just being willing
to have the conversations and,
you know, talk to the
difficult things.
I think that can be really helpful.
As we all know, we know the
numbers 1% of the population serves
or has served in this war.
But I think the number
is actually 13%
of the American population
are veterans, right,
of the different wars and
the different generations.
I don't know the exact percentage
of the American population
that is related to those
veterans but I'm pretty sure most
of us have some sort
of relationship.
Even in my own family, I have
four different touch points,
not even my own in terms of
people who served in the military.
So, I think just having those
conversations being willing
to listen, being willing
to not judge,
I think, can be really important.
The public humanities, I
think, can bridge that.
There are programs that are
happening across the country
that intend to bring military and
civilians together in the same room.
Often times, in my
role, they are the base.
So, you know, a show
will be performed.
And at the end of the show, there
will be a talk back and we'll talk
about AJAX, and what does AJAX mean
to the vets in the room but also
to the civilians in the room
in relation to each other.
So, there is ways to do these things
and people are already doing them.
I do believe, just having
a willingness to listen
and to engage a conversation
sort of the first step.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie:
Let me add one point quickly,
which is before you do
anything, see what the needs are.
There's often a lot of people
want to provide free something,
send them to the veterans
at Walter Reed
who are just inundated
with donations.
And one need that is consistent and
under appreciated, a female veteran
who are young, who have
children, who have-- are homeless.
They often don't fit into
the kind of veteran SRO,
single residency occupant, you know.
And there aren't enough
places for them.
Unfortunately, in the military,
there's about twice the
unintended pregnancy rate
as in the civilian world.
Many of those women can't juggle
both couple of small children
and the military and they
may be single or divorced
or perhaps married but
too many of them are
out on the streets
with a small children.
So that's a really important
need that isn't being addressed.
>> Tara Galovski: And I think Dr.
Ritchie said this earlier the idea
that give the veteran some space.
The re-integration is a
very different process
across veterans in my experience.
And as a college professor,
a lot of--
we had a lot of student veterans.
And so, we got to see some
of those processes, you know,
juggling small kids,
being a little bit older
than the traditional student for
example, having to juggle career
and certainly education
and so forth.
And watching those worlds collide
with individuals who hadn't served
and trying to understand
that military culture.
So, trying to find the common place
to meet people where they're at
and understand what it
is that veteran needs
that might be very different
from the next veteran's needs.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
OK. We're going to have one
more group discussion question
and then we're going to open
the floor for the audience.
Are there alternative or
complementary therapies
that you believe are under-utilized?
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie:
There absolutely are.
The challenges with what's called
integrated medicine or complementary
and alternative medicine is
that we don't have good
science behind much--
though the science is emerging.
So, for example, acupuncture
and yoga, meditation,
we now have the sciences to show
that in some people,
they're really helpful.
One of my favorite pet therapies
is working with dogs or horses.
Cats don't do it, neither
do goldfish.
But there's a lot of, in a sense,
bio-feedback that you can do.
There's controversy about
service dogs and other technique
which is relatively new, it's
called Stellate Ganglion Block,
its lidocaine and the
stellate ganglion.
I was quoted in Playboy
recently and an article about it
and they called it the God
shot because with some people,
it was really helpful
to dramatically reduce
their PTSD symptoms.
Special Forces won't go near
a psychiatrist, but they'll go
to somebody who will
give them a shot to help
with their knee pain, for example.
So, yes, there's a lot
of good stuff out there
and that's another area we
do need congressional support
to get the funding.
Unfortunately, pharmaceutical
companies don't fund,
studies of dog therapy.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie:
And so, we got to go there.
>> Karen L. Fears: Yeah.
>> Tara Galovski: Yes.
I think there's absolutely a
place for these alternative
and non-traditional routes.
I just actually published
a trial looking at hypnosis
for PTSD sleep-related
impairment which is a huge problem
and we found we are--
my hypothesis was
if we can get people sleeping
better, right, we all feel better
when we get a goodnight sleep.
>> Karen L. Fears: Yes.
>> Tara Galovski: Then people
can engage with the process
of recovery a little bit more.
And that was actually
funded by the complementary
and alternative institute at NIH.
And we found that we were able to
directly target sleep impairment
that was very specific to
PTSD and people were able
to get some restore to sleep.
And that it didn't actually
influence their ability to recover
from PTSD, right, CPG was
quite even in that respect
but it did influence people's
recovery and depression.
And so, it kind of have that--
it lifted that added burden
off of people's plates,
so I think that there's
all kinds of avenues
and the more choices we have,
the better able we are served.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
Thank you, and Dr. Wrenn?
>> Glenda Wrenn: I really agree
with everything that's been said.
We're also doing research
on sleep as a diagnostic
and predictive tool for PTSD.
There's work happening in
the Atlanta VA around yoga.
Because, again, it's building
the evidence but then you want
to be able to fund the
things that have evidence
and not just continuing to
support things that have been
around for a long time but
don't work for everyone.
So, I think it's good to continue
to explore other options especially
when you see that there
are still a lot of gaps
and people not accessing
care that needed.
It's not always the person
that's doing something wrong,
sometime it's the treatment
that's not been properly tailored.
Strength base interventions
and resilience based intervention
is also might be effective
in their ability to kind of overcome
some of the barriers by connecting
where people already
feel comfortable,
then you can introduce some
of those effective elements
of exposure based interventions.
So, I think there is still
a lot of work that we can do
to develop effective treatments and
that includes a range of options.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie: Yeah.
I work down in Southern
Maryland now one day a week
and Southern Maryland is
kind of rural Charlotte Hall.
So, I ask people what
they like to do
and a fair amount would
like to fish or to boat.
And they find that that's
become their own self-guided,
so over a command.
OK. You know, let's make sure
you do some more fishing.
And at times with the PTSD,
they will be scared to go
out of their house, so you have
to help them bridge through that.
But build on what people
already know and enjoy.
And we haven't mentioned writing
as a therapeutic modality,
but certainly, writing
and art therapy.
Many people don't like to
talk about what happened,
but they can paint a mask.
And so, there's a, you know, again,
the theme here range
of different options.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
Great. Thank you.
Maurice?
>> Maurice DeCaul: Yeah.
And I'll say again, with writings,
as you mentioned Dr. Ritchie
in my experience, in my
personal experience as well.
You know, it can be very helpful.
I never talked about the
war, six years back from Iraq
and never talked about
it until I got to NYU
and started that writing workshop.
And they taught me
how to write poetry.
And then I started
writing all these poems.
So, yeah, writing, art.
I have lots of friends
who are artist.
They're sculptures,
they are painters.
The outdoors is also
I think very helpful.
There are programs
that already exist.
Outward bound does these adventure
programs throughout the country.
You can go kayaking or sailing
or mountain climbing or skiing
or whatever it is that you
want to do and whatever kind
of challenge you want to
challenge yourself physically,
they can provide it for you.
So, there are many different
ways that I've seen with folks
that I know and even with myself.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
Great, great.
Thank you panel you've just
done a wonderful job today.
Thank you so much.
And so, at this time, we would
like to open up the floor
for any questions that the audience
may have for any of the panelist?
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie:
And it looks like they're
grabbing a mic for the audience.
And if we could just add,
I always like to know
who is asking the question.
So, if you could just
introduce yourself briefly.
>> Does this work?
Hello? My name is Dr. Chris Nelson.
I'm-- actually, I used to
be a civilian psychiatrist
and for the past five years I've
been working at Camp Lejeune
with the PTSD clinic which I think
is extremely gratifying work.
And I just wanted to say
parenthetically that I totally agree
with Dr. Wrenn that the military
cultural competence piece is very
much missing in that kind of
work that I've been doing.
And I have to say, I've kind
of learn from my mistakes
as a civilian contract psychiatrist.
But I think, you know, it's
extremely exciting work.
And if anybody knows other shrinks
that are sick of what they're doing,
want to do something else I would
suggest that they try to work
with the PTSD population,
because these patients
desperately need the help
and they do get better.
But, I had a question for
Dr. Galovski about something
that I've heard about and that
is something called accelerated
resolution therapy which is
apparently a kind of a condense
or sort of a, you know,
compressed version
of the standard prolonged
exposure protocol.
And I wonder if you
have any understanding
of whether that's proven
successful so far?
And if so, could we kind
of beat this problem Dr. Ritchie was
mentioning of people not being able
to stay with like with 20 different
sessions of prolonged exposure?
>> Tara Galovski: Yeah.
That's a good example of that.
I don't-- that remains to be
seen with that specific therapy
but prolonged exposure, they've
published to mass interventions now
where they've done the
entire protocol in two weeks.
And we actually just this
week submitted a proposal
to do cognitive processing
therapy in one week.
And when I look at my-- I've
read a number of RCTs myself
and when I look at my drop-out
rates, people aren't dropping
out because they can't
tolerate the therapy.
They're dropping out because
life is getting in the way.
My patients have gone
back to prison.
My patients have-- had
their homes foreclosed
and need to move some place else.
My patients have gotten a
life-threatening medical diagnosis
and, you know, and so forth.
And so, I think that that is the
solution to getting people engaged
and getting people over that hump.
You know, it's-- we have found
that when someone comes in,
they're kind of at that rock bottom
place often times and striking while
that iron is hot is critical.
We've had-- I've run a couple of
trials where we've done something
like motivational interviewing
and then CPT or like I was talking
about my sleep project, then CPT.
And that that window there
are drop-out rates go
through the roof even though
that's precisely what we're trying
to decrease as drop-out rates.
And I think it's because folks come
in and they're ready to go and we,
as the clinician, for good reasons,
sometimes, put on the breaks.
And so, what happens
is that someone,
you know, they shy away from it.
So, if someone could
commit to one week, come in,
move through the protocol, think
through the memory differently,
come to different conclusions,
learn that they can safely engage
with that memory so the
process of habituation.
Imagine that you could do that
in one week and then walk away.
And so, P has done and CPT
has not yet very successfully
with huge effect sizes and
very low drop-out rates.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie:
We've got a question
back here too, I think.
>> Yes. Hi, I'm a student
here for actually for my son
and actually always been
interesting for me is that,
my ex service in Vietnam twice.
We went through PTSD while I
was going through PTSD for being
of four-time cancer survivor.
And so, at the time, my son
and daughter were very young.
But then later on, my son
went to Bosnia, Somalia
and then now I wrap five times in
dessert storm and dessert shield.
And so, now, I'm seeing
all the stuff
that he is going through with PTSD.
One of the things I'm just
trying to figure out is
that with the VA hospital, they not
putting more money into programs
to bring in more people
because it seems
to be waiting list all the time
for him getting to workshops.
So, if anything has needs to
be done, the congress needs
to put more money in that area
so they can help them out there
because it's really in
and out thing for my son.
And I remember when he came
just back from Somalia,
he couldn't touch baby for a
long time because her body sore.
And being in Iraq and been in the
dessert storm and dessert shielding,
it's been really quite right.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie:
So, there's lot there.
And first, thank him for
his service and thank you
and your husband for their service.
Let me take a little piece of that.
I'm also seeing a lot of Vietnam era
veterans who have been doing fine
for 30, 40 years now
they're in their 70s
and their symptoms are
emerging, especially,
as they're often now
retired, perhaps ill,
perhaps if loss to spouse.
And so, the point I was
going to make on this is
that it's not something that
you have and then it's over.
It can be triggered easily,
it can come back again.
In terms of your son, that's
probably a longer conversation,
especially, is he still
active duty because act
of duty troops don't want to
go see a shrink very often?
>> Karen L. Fears: Right.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie: So,
there are all the treatments we've
talked about are now available,
but there's often a lot
of reluctance to engage.
And so, as you were saying, you
got to strike while the iron is hot
when they're ready to engage.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
>> Hi. My name is Sarah Mcneilus.
I am an MST and PTSD
survivor, sorry.
>> Karen L. Fears: It's OK.
>> Sarah Mcneilus: It's a
lot of the anxiety something
that you deal with all the time.
I am also married to an
active duty service member
who just returned from Afghanistan.
And one of the things that we
struggled with there was a lack
of access to mental healthcare
for him, specifically,
with some of the things that
he was seeing over there.
And one of the things that we did
as a family, I found a therapist
in New York who would
Skype with him.
He originally didn't want to
do therapy at all with the--
There was a British
therapist that he could see
that was where he was stationed.
But he also had privacy
concerns about who had access
to those mental health records
as an active duty service member.
So I guess my question to the
panel is what are your feelings
on that lack of privacy
and that lack of access
that the active duty
service members might have
because these PTSD doesn't happen
when they become a veteran,
it happens as a result
of their active service.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
>> And we're not really
doing anything
to combat that at that level.
We're focusing on trying to
treat them after they have left.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie: So
the military actually has set
up a fair amount of alternative
programs exactly for those reasons.
Military OneSource, there is
something called, Given an Hour,
there is other places, chaplains
where there is more confidentiality.
But, there's always a balance
between the question of fitness
for duty and somebody
having total privacy.
So, some of those sources and we
can talk afterwards if you want
to know how to get involved in
some of the alternative treatments
that he can do when
he's on active duty.
>> Glenda Wrenn: I also just
wanted to mention in terms
of alternate treatments, virtual
reality treatments for PTSD there.
Barbara Rothbaum who is also
in Atlanta has spearheaded.
And that's also maybe
more helpful for people
that have combat specific PTSD for
which that type of an approach.
It also is a little
different than the circle
of a group and, you know, exposure.
I think the therapies really do
vary and that that's another example
of one that has incredible
evidence and it's very effective.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie:
And for those who didn't know,
virtual reality, it's usually
with the computer or TV screen.
And there's a virtual
Iraq or Afghanistan
so that you can be exposed to say,
the sound of gun shot or explosions,
but you can turn it up or turn
it down as you can tolerate it.
>> Tara Galovski: It also
sounds like Skype was something
that was helpful to him and
a lot of these interventions.
All of the evidence based ones
really had been tested using
telemental health.
And so, there might be-- if that
might be an option down the road
if that was something
that was palatable to him.
>> OK.
>> Hi. My name is Elizabeth.
I worked with the Defense and
Veterans Brain Injury Center.
So, my question involves a
dual diagnosis of TBI and PTSD.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie:
And substance abuse.
Don't forget substance abuse.
>> Sure, yes.
And I'm just curious if
the presence of a mild
or moderate TBI changes the way
that you approach the PTSD treatment
and if it changes the amount
of success that you're seeing,
if they could be treated at the same
time, so just a gambit of questions
around that duel diagnosis.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie: So,
most of the patients I see are dual
or triple or quadruple
by a diagnosis.
I mentioned substance of use there's
a lot of pain disability in there.
The modality that I used
is no longer, "Pure PTSD".
I don't know if there
was ever a pure PTSD,
but we certainly will assess all
of the different parts of this.
I'm actually really gotten much
more into physical therapy recently
because a lot of my patients
are putting on weight
and because of their knee pain.
And then that contributes to
their lack of self-esteem,
which contributes to
their sexual problems.
So, exercises in there.
And certainly, if you're going
to be doing something cognitive,
you need to see for TBI.
It's all in there absolutely.
>> Tara Galovski: We published
a paper recently that suggested
that the cognitive processing
therapy with there's a side
of the Cincinnati VA and that folks
with mild and moderate TBI did just
as well as folks without.
And this is program.
And this isn't just one course.
This isn't just those 12 sessions.
These are in a unit that has
a lot of supports around it.
I think that the data
suggests both academically,
but also in my clinical experience
that the supports are critical.
So the lapses in concentration and
those pieces, you need other tools
to help move through
these interventions.
But, it is really-- there's emerging
data right now that's coming out of
on the brain banks in Boston,
in our tracks programs there
that are looking at this
really quite remarkably.
And it really is PTSD,
depression and TBI when the three
of those are onboard which I
think the estimates were about 30%
of our folks with PTSD,
that is really--
we were seeing the cases that
aren't resolving that PTSD.
That's kind of like
that triple threat.
It's tough.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
>> Elspeth Cameron Ritchie: Maybe I
know we're going to end in a moment.
One way to think about this is you
hear about the signature wounds
of the war being PTSD and TBI
but my former [Inaudible],
a sergeant general in the army,
General Scott Mac [assumed spelling]
are used to talk about the blast
as a signature weapon of the war,
which causes not only PTSD and TBI,
but also hearing lost because
your ear drums get blown up,
maybe facial disfigurement,
burns, of course loss
of legs, loss of genitals.
So, it's a little bit
different than other wars.
People who survive this war, they
would have died in other wars.
You got to Walter Reed and
you see the triple amputees.
So, these can be really,
really complex cases.
And PTSD is about one
part of the whole.
>> Karen L. Fears: OK.
Great. OK.
All right then.
Well, I just want to take
this opportunity to thank all
of the panelists who
shared with us today.
And I'm truly humble to be here
and to serve in this capacity
because this is a therapy from me.
The more I'm able to speak about
these, about PTSD as a result
of sexual assault, and
sexual intimidation,
rape or whatever the case
may be, it helps me to heal.
And so, I'm just hoping and
praying that that would be an outlet
for anyone else who is out here
experiencing the same thing.
So, Dr. Wrenn, I want to thank
you for being here with us today,
Dr. Galovski, Dr. Ritchie
and Maurice DeCaul.
And thank you guys so
much for joining us today.
And you can just meet with
the panelist afterwards.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.